Game of Thrones is over won't live Game
of Thrones hey there and welcome to
Westeros weekly the show that answers
your biggest questions about every
episode of Game of Thrones we are fresh
back from New York kind of hungover I
think I left my hat there uh-huh Phillip
Melina and I'm Erik Voss hi whoo we had
a hell of a show guys it was so amazing
to get to meet so many of you out in
Brooklyn thanks to the hotel red line
for that that was like the exact
experience I wanted to have I wanted to
watch it with so many amazing fans
everybody in that room was a die-hard
fan and we just to experience so many of
the best moments with them oh yeah we've
never had that experience before seeing
it with a huge group with all the
highlights the episode is feeling that
much more punctuated like when Jon Snow
kills Daenerys so that that got that
huge reaction and which I thought could
not be topped I think it was it may have
been topped you can definitely see me on
the on the side there when Jon Snow pets
ghost was more of a catharsis for people
I think we felt that catharsis a bit
more there - yeah there was two guys
that did a double high-five in that
moment it just it was just perfect
that's exactly what it deserved but man
just having the the crowd explode in
those moments was so amazing we are
going to get to everything that we
normally get to in Westeros weekly we're
gonna have a big question that we're
gonna tackle in a minute we're also
going to have a lot of other questions
from you guys we're gonna go over and
our death pool finally has a winner and
all these things but first we we just
wanna we did a live show there and we we
that was literally right after the
episode ended so we had a real authentic
snap reactions right then of just how we
were feeling but we don't want to
deprive you guys of that too so we're
just kind of gonna give some of the
thoughts we had about the finale and
this is stuff if you were of the people
that were there in a at the live show
then you've heard this before but for
the rest of you man like like wonder
what an episode right and it gave some
sense of finality to all the characters
especially if you look at you know the
whole series how much the Starks have
been beaten down and how this family
episode end up as a Vic
three four teams stark and several
different ways but also as a kind of the
answer to the question we've had about
Daenerys is descent into darkness
throughout this season how she became a
villainous character and how that felt a
little sudden in Episode five this
episode kind of had some meta
conversations the debate between John
and Tyrion kind of serving as a
surrogate debate that was happening
among the fans over whether or not it
was justified which is pretty prescient
that they were able to understand what
the arguments were gonna be and you know
was there enough and I I think that the
writers were speaking through Tyrion and
apparently what this was very much
needed when he was recapping all of the
different you know essentially war
crimes that Daenerys Targaryen has
committed he they were kind of saying
like did you guys forget that she was on
her way there the whole time whether or
not I still have to have issues with
what the exact way it was done I'm
making a whole other video about that
but I do think that they were absolutely
right that you know the warning signs
were there absolutely and it felt like
this the whole season has been doing
this but kind of reminding us of
everyone's past actions in their past
journey the way that scene reminded us
of the fact that Jon Snow was
resurrected and this isn't just
something that the show just did a
couple seasons ago that we were meant to
forget about and pretend never happened
no they deliberately reminded us that he
has this kind of power the Lord of Light
and he has this kind of symbolic destiny
that he's meant to fulfill and in the
breakdown they get into more the
specific imagery of how that could be
the case and we'll talk about this on
and on and and weeks going forward but
it John did play a significant role
there were some potential prophecies
confirmed by his killing of his love
Daenerys she could potentially be an
asana so figure in the azure High
prophecy we did see imagery of flaming
swords when drogon melt the iron throne
and the the world was rid of darkness in
a way Daenerys was an at least equally
great threat to the livelihood of the
people of Westeros that the night King
was so despite Arya serving as a
champion of the Lord of Light in the
Battle of Winterfell
you could definitely be argued that John
was a champion of the Lord of Light in
this finale episode and I think just
staying on this idea of the prophecies
that came to pass or you know were
ignored potential
in this episode just you you're so you
have a whole video coming of prophesies
in theory is that that were paid off
some that weren't but I do want to
acknowledge a more subtle one that was
paid off it's only subtle at first or
not so harshly at first and that's the
vision from the house of the undying
that danny has where she's gonna be
walking through the red keep the top is
blown off turns out I was probably a mix
of snow and ash as well as falling and
they do a lot of shop for shot
recreation so we all remember that
that's playing out you know exactly how
it did then the thing that I think we
didn't realize then but retroactively a
we could realized spoiled all of Game of
Thrones was that originally that vision
that she had ends abruptly and suddenly
she finds herself with Khal Drogo and
her unborn child
reunited somehow now looking back you
can probably realize oh that's why
that's the last moments of her life and
then she's in the afterlife again with
her you know the the man she loved and
the baby she never got to have carried
by the dragon that is her son in a way
metaphorically speaking and also
represent right yes so it does come full
circle in that way so if you're willing
to have a detached look at some of these
prophecies which you should because they
are metaphorical the show did deliver on
these it's they weren't just brought up
and hopefully the book will continue to
explore them more because prophecy of
mythology yeah yeah winds of winter in
the dream of spring well dig into these
more because it's always been more
present in the books and they've been on
the show uh real quick I think we should
also just this just something we went
over in in the live show but I think
it's worth acknowledging just some
favorite moments from the episode I know
we we I think we both had you know a
gasp worthy what we had a couple moment
I know we caught you on camera gasping a
certain moment but when we reacted just
to the wings of drogon spreading behind
Danny there just for a moment it felt
like a nod to the theory that some
people had which was maybe one of the
craziest theories was at the end of the
series
you know Daenerys the dragon inside of
her would crack through her skin and
she'd become a full-blown it was it
created this illusion of metamorphosis
physical transformation the threat that
the Mad King Aerys a second and viscera
promised that they had the power to do
Daenerys is going
step further by showing she actually has
the capability of dragon power and
dragon fire and that was just little nod
to the book that her mad brother and
father made this promise she's actually
able to deliver on it I like that you
you you're making that point about
metamorphosis too because it is the the
straight-up cough cover version of it
where you become the actual beast fully
and if anything that you know is what
Daenerys was at the end where we don't
think of dragons is necessarily they've
gone mad right it's just like the dragon
is as the dragon does yeah and there's
there's not two like the Greek ovid
metamorphoses as well this idea of by
humans transforming into the Beast you
kind of boil down to the pure essence of
something that in a way becomes easier
to destroy as though we saw Denarius
kind of melt down from a complex human
figure to just a pure rage-filled dragon
who's willing to spread that rage on and
fire all over the world in a way makes
it easier for John to kill her yeah and
then on the opposite side of the
spectrum I just love saying a sassy
Sansa telling her uncle to sit down no I
say it every year at Thanksgiving too it
never works she's gonna speaking for
everyone in that moment like at Myrtle
why are you even was just like what
exactly you had an episode basically and
you were captured no I loved that moment
and I mean obviously that goes petting
putting John moment you can see me and
then that moment freaking out and
standing on someone's shoulders yes that
final montage beautifully composed by
Ramin Djawadi kind of the 11:00 fan of
this show with the extra character who
brings so much to this yeah it someone
did put like a John Hughes kind of music
overly cheesy yeah
I'm speaking of that blog so I think we
should probably acknowledge just where
these characters ended up and and you
know how we feel about that obviously
his answer we were just alluding to
queen odin Orff yes Queen Noor felt like
full circle for a lot of people were
wanted her to be queen of Westeros as a
whole but in a way just becoming queen
of just de Norv as its own independent
nation is an even greater victory for
her because that's where her true
allegiance lies and
she were queen of Westeros it would be
clear she would always show preferential
treatment and potentially create further
divisions and conflicts between the
kingdom can imagine her visiting Dorne
right it's never been interesting she's
never had any luck south and the
Riverlands is always a dark time for
sure I mean her family doesn't have luck
going south right so in the north that's
where she belongs
this is what she's always wanted and I
think just she's always wanted
independence in an autonomy for the
north so the fact that she was able to
achieve that is in many ways an even
greater victory for her than the victory
for bran was by winning the iron yeah or
what's left of it for me I just I just
saw it as Canada right it's the
formation of Canada basically where it's
like you know what this thing is bigger
than everything else right then the
north on its own is incredibly vast of
course there's even beyond the north but
there's also beyond Canada I've heard
it's where Santa lives
well in some our UK listeners and
followers may compare it to Scotland and
how recently Scotland wanted to secede
from the UK
that brings me to actually I think
that's more like the Iron Islands and I
think we are getting to to discuss that
later in the episode of what's up with
Yara Greyjoy and where the welcome to
talk about why haven't other kingdoms
wanted and or push for independence in
that moment yeah what about the other
people who we saw the in the little
council what to think of them where they
ended up I thought it was fitting to see
Sam become the archmaester to see Davos
become master of ships a little odd to
see Bronn become master of coin because
I don't see that guy having any kind of
financial mastery or there's no way he
knows any math right yes yeah even
Daenerys showed that she had trouble
with math as a kid not knowing the
difference between twenty eight thousand
pain that again and again remember I got
kicked in the head by a horse and I
don't know what 20 it smells like so I
think bran was given that position as
kind of a punishment because when Tyrion
was made master of coin by Tywin in
earlier seasons and it was kind of
almost a slap in the face the way Cersei
made mace Tyrell master of coin in
addition to master of ships it's more of
a burden than like a great job but you
can't like bright eye that well it's
like the treasure in your club who
actually like decides whether or not you
guys succeed but everyone graduate and
it's just like the nerd who just want to
shut up so you get that job also
Highgarden is
in the reaches like they're one of the
richest regions of Westeros so maybe
just by his financial acumen well yeah
he probably discovered a lot of because
I don't think they have digital banking
so I think in his castle there probably
is just like a collection of prizes and
and gold and whatnot but you know I
guess he now owns yeah I'm a little
mixed in my feelings of seeing Brienne
of Tarth become Lord Commander of the
Kingsguard not that she's not worthy of
it
it just seems like the the monarch that
she's more loyal to loyal to is the
monarch of the other neighboring
independent country she could be Queen's
Guard to Sansa Stark of the north
she doesn't have to be Queen's Guard or
Kingsguard to brand Stark no she hasn't
really shown much little sure but but
you could easily have seen had they
known that brain was still alive maybe
that would have been part of the vow to
Catelyn Stark would just take care of my
children or maybe then also she is
someone who did not start in the north
right I mean you know she she look she
looks good up there but she might
actually like like going and uh it
seemed like the show wanted her in the
south so that she could fulfill Jaime's
obituary and his epilogue is essentially
that that book moment was nice to see
her fill in the book of brothers but it
just seems something that was more for
Jaime trying to give us some closure and
Jaime rather than closure for Brienne
yeah now I wonder I mean this is just a
kind of a nerd question about you know
if if one Kingdom respects the the
knighthood of another's because
technically she was knighted by Sir
Jaime mm-hmm and so she might kind of
belong in that line Oh to the blue yes
I'm not sure someone will correct me
aggressively so actually then a in the
live event here one of my favorite
moments is that we got to start us flew
out to winners that have been asking
questions all season long really great
questions and we actually had so what
we'll we'll revisit their questions
throughout this episode but one of them
is actually kind of I think like one of
the big questions that a lot of us have
been just debating about and thinking
about and I love the way that our
starters winner Nevin put it so it's go
ahead and play an Evans question from
our live event so my question is is
brand the biggest evil mastermind of
them all yeah because he
literally worked himself into the Iron
Throne great question by the way that
whole live show you can listen to the
audio version of it on our podcast feed
if you go to the Westeros weekly feed
you can listen to our whole discussion
it's a really fun event that's our
that's all they're also just really
quick we got to give a thank you to a
sponsor that helps us make this whole
series all of Westeros weekly this
season so it's a quick shout out to
posts mates you can download the post
mates app for iOS or Android for free
and get whatever you want delivered
year-round browse local stores and
restaurants and you can track your
delivery along the way which I get
obsessive about doing post makes brings
you what you want within the hour but 24
hours a day they have that available I
literally swear god I used in the middle
of the night last night because I was
super hungover as I said but uh what
else and I just needed some carnitas oh
my god that's seven days a week 365 days
a year
food groceries whatever you need
delivered they have the largest
on-demand merchant network in the known
universe which they've checked them I'm
sure it's been verified the only thing
they can't deliver is any more Game of
Thrones episodes unfortunately but I
post is actually giving our listeners
$100 of free delivery credit for the
first 7 days that you use it so to start
those three deliveries hundred bucks
free delivery credits download the app
right now use the code rockstars as the
code rockstars again 100 dollars of free
delivery credits for your first 7 days
when you download the post Nights app
get anything you need any time you need
it download post mates and save with the
code rockstars
okay so we're answering this question a
bad question the big question what was
brands plan was this whole thing that we
saw at the end of the show Brandt's plan
all along is he master manipulator
yes which it's interesting cuz you can
you can look back at the past season or
the past series really but it all ends
with bran is the unexpected winner of
The Game of Thrones because he knows
everything past present and future and
we know he saw this coming because he
told Tyrion why do you think I came all
this way sassy little B and so it's
possible that he doesn't see every move
moment moment but he knew enough to know
that he would become king
and that he would have to take the crown
to serve as Lord Protector of the six
realms well and to reminder he was
offered to be the the Lord of you know
in the north of Winterfell and in the
warden of the north and anyone you play
maybe I've seen the the me more city
he's like oh no no thank you I don't
really want any more and then it's like
oh what about King he's like why you
came I think I came all this way and
it's like oh so was that a lie but I
think we're fine I mean our my
assumption at least is no it actually
was I don't really want your nonsense
because that's not part of the bigger
plan right or you can also read it as
bran didn't want this lower level
position as part of his destiny to show
the world that he does not want power so
if he was warned or the north that would
count against him during this big
council meeting was like well he took
this this lower level position of power
warden of the north
Lord of Winterfell so the guy does want
power instead tiering can better make
the claim that this is the one person
here who does not want any power he
doesn't want any part of the political
games that makes them that much more
worthy of taking the role as king also
look at any person who's made it clear
that they do want to be king or queen it
does not end well for them yes everyone
who's wanted it has lost in some way or
another
yeah Jerry an early earlier in the
episode told Jon nothing's more
dangerous than the rightful heir to the
Iron Throne which i think is kind of the
deeper theme of this this episode and
you could argue the whole series that
really it's super dangerous when you
have someone who has risen to a certain
level of power who wants more power and
they're within arm's reach arm's reach
of it you got to watch out for that
person so instead it's kind of like what
Tolkien has said in Lord of the Rings
that The Hobbit is the most worthy of
bearing the ring because their souls are
the most uncorruptible they're humble
they have no want for power
they're both physically and
metaphorically with a way of arms reach
of any real power so in the same way I
think Tyrion is kind of alluding to that
argument with brand he's the most worthy
because he doesn't want it and I think
also Tyrion is alluding to that we joked
a lot in a live show about what a dick
name and nickname he gives them
so bring the broken over here and
Santa's like and his dick don't work but
he keeps repeating bran the broken brand
the broken and it's like yeah we get it
you want the nickname mistake but
actually if you think about it from this
perspective of he's trying he's also
doing a PR move right right there of
explaining this is a different system
and that does actually work for of all
people standing there right there
grey worm right he was following the
person who wanted to break the wheel
well how about the broken boy the broken
man right that that doesn't sound like
something that's from the previous wheel
also he knows something about wheels
yeah that's true but let's look back at
brands moves how far back was this plan
in place right has he been Littlefinger
from the beginning yeah and we could
look at early early on in season one he
received that cryptic dream from the
three-eyed raven that he didn't
understand that moment that you will fly
and in the books he had the dream of
flying over Westeros II know for
everything and then when he actually met
the three-eyed raven he told him you'll
never walk again but you will fly which
tyrion alludes to in this scene the boy
who never walked again but he flew so
maybe from that level from that moment
bran is starting to see a future for him
for himself and then in season six once
he becomes the three-eyed Raven he
actually had a vision of much of the
conflict to come over the next couple
seasons he saw wildfire tearing through
the the tunnels beneath King's Landing
shadow the dragon he saw the shine of
the Dragon Daenerys his dragon drogon
flying over Kings land and burning it so
we knew that both Cersei would become a
mad queen and Daenerys would become a
mad queen things that would cancel each
other out and create a PowerPoint and
then later on comes to realize that Jon
Snow is Aegon Targaryen yes so if he's
and he knows that secret paired with the
fact that there's gonna be this issue
between Daenerys and Cersei and he knows
there's a rightful king he also knows
that he can divide up the the faith
behind Daenerys by telling Sam and
letting the word get out that John is
actually the true heir to the Iron
Throne so that move right there telling
telling Sam at all could have been a
strategic move just to set up Daenerys
is split of her her counselors
absolutely and it's also a strategic
move to tell John it's your choice
in the godswood to
tell his sisters he is empowering John
to make these decisions so that later
that will have a ripple effect when he's
talking to Tyrion who also says in this
episode they don't she doesn't get to
choose but you do you know and then when
Daenerys when their embrace in that
moment she says the other people who
might know what's good in the world
don't get to choose we get to choose so
Jon in that moment feels that sense of
power it honestly goes all the way back
to when a bond Aemon Targaryen at the
wall said a day will come when men get
to choose between duty and love and that
choice bran is lighting ablaze and John
so that he will fulfill his destiny as
this is or a high figure to be the one
to kill Daenerys which will also take
him off the plane board as well yeah and
I'm just throw out there obviously we've
we've talked about this does he get the
the night King off of the board just by
giving arya the dagger oh for sure he's
just like alright we'll take care of
that aureole move move move in and take
care of that threat and then I'm still
playing the political game on the side
that's why man I wish we knew exactly
what he told Tyrion in that conversation
yeah the the battle of at the Battle of
Winterfell where that whole conversation
could be like you know I mean like I
don't I said never be king I'm not
saying me but whoever is king should you
know like maybe it's it's gonna be for
us to argue over and over the ages
whether bran wanted this whether he's
like he has ambition lust for power the
way Littlefinger did and little thing
was like manipulating things behind the
scenes using chaos as a ladder I don't
personally read brand that way it's hard
to judge a book by its cover
you weren't a good tree trying to trying
to reach for a tree joke there
I see bran is someone who's telling the
truth when he says he doesn't want it I
by seeing these things in the future I
think the way time travel and visions of
the future work in Game of Thrones you
can't change it it's fixed on a destined
predestined path and he's just playing
his role in that destiny and he views
probably someone who has a impartiality
toward the events and the conflicts of
Westeros someone who's
really killed anyone as the most right
king figure to in this game of thrones
and lead it to a potentially peaceful
scenario where future rulers are chosen
rather than born yeah we want an
assistant alive show a little bit but
you know the the concept of democracy
clearly is a little far too off right
there's still a couple generations away
from drug sea which I'm in America right
but then the concept of an oligarchy or
whatever exactly is that they had they
have that is such a hugely that is a
broken wheel that that would take a
level of foresight you know that only
one person has yeah and you could argue
that in the early days of the American
Republic that was the sort of the system
that the founding fathers envisioned not
a direct democracy where presidents
unfortunately are not chosen through a
popular vote but a republic an electoral
college a representative government
senators were used to be chosen by you
know States rather than direct democracy
within States and they wanted these
barriers to mob rule which i think is
what a lot of these elitists lords of
westeros are worried about this mob rule
were really these savages that are our
people are gonna vote decide who leads
them it a republic a republic is a step
away from that where it's still a form
of representative government but not a
direct democracy because I guess these
people are elitist oligarchs who believe
that people cannot be trusted with that
power but hey maybe someday in the
future cool so I think that mostly
covers it that yeah he's a master
manipulator he's been playing everyone
the whole time yeah or not I think it'd
be fun but let's let's put on the
timeline maybe to string together a
video compilation of just all the brands
moments and we'll see how they
absolutely right time to move on to
another section of the show that we do
before we get to more questions we
always mourn the lost their watch is
ended yeah we call this in memoriam here
a little more and there's only one
character we want to focus on here one
big character Daenerys Targaryen the
mother of dragons
the
unburnt is that I still am the movie
frozen she's letting it go yeah the
Daenerys actually is interesting we'll
talk more about some Lord of the Rings
parallels but you can compare Daenerys
isarc here to Gollum someone who's
turning into full corrupted with her
lust for power now Iron Throne being
kind of a ring of power kind of figure
but yeah she she her lust for the Iron
Throne blew up in her face and over you
could argue over the past two seasons
she's been gradually slipping into this
path of darkness I I agree that last
episode it was a bit abrupt to see her
go full crazy and and decimate sorry I
keep saying decimate I get it right
destroy not decimate half a mate
street-by-street of innocent people she
did not need to do that and whatever
argument or justification she tried to
use will never make sense to me because
she could have just aimed directly for
the red keep but you can see how she
snapped and emotionally why she made
that choice Emilia Clarke's performance
yeah and because they didn't give her
lines to do she didn't on her face and
you know what kudos to Emilia Clarke in
her portrayal of her death scene I
thought the acting of that scene between
Kit Harington Emilia were was amazing
she played it with such steadfast
conviction the smile that she had in the
face on her face if only you could see
what I could see it's difficult to see
things that have never been it's sad for
her because you believe her in that
moment you just know that she's wrong
he's also the most human she's been in
seasons in that moment in fact I think
she probably went back to like a season
2 season 3 Daenerys performance there
and just reminded you of the young girl
with a vision yeah Clarke had said that
in her final breath that she was trying
to show that vulnerability of herself as
a little girl in season 1 she keeps
referencing it but I will point out ok
I'm not saying Daenerys did nothing
wrong but Daenerys did nothing wrong no
it's not true I think it was very bad
too but I we do got acknowledged so she
wanted to break the wheel right yes does
she actually break the wheel if she
takes power no and she said she asked at
a tyrant but she's replaced
without her herself is she's gonna be
this this awful dictator we can all see
where it's going but by burning all
these people and making it so that her
lover feels that he has to kill her and
that her most trusted advisors you know
all feel like yes she needs to die then
they result in a whole different system
of government after that yeah did she
not break the wheel by burning down
King's Landing was it required yeah I I
believe so and I think by breaking the
wheel she might have forgotten that
she's also part of that wheel and in
that wheel of a different house is holes
that we see in the opening credits
among them is a Targaryen dragon so by
breaking the wheel she has to go down
with that wheel and open the door for
someone unexpected to take power after
that also as we mentioned before her
death does services kind of sacrificial
metaphorical figure to the Lord of
Lights as or a high prophecy fulfilled
she just represented so much darkness
and this in these final episodes that
she needed to die in order for there to
be any kind of dream of spring a light
bringer yeah so that's a that's our in
memoriam we miss you baby yes but let's
move on to more questions
oh I forgot that's part of this show
okay dude a dragon wants to know where
is John going okay so at the end there
so in our final shots we see a real good
boy get his pets mm-hmm and then we see
John and the episode and the whole
series is the last stuff we see by
writing north beyond the wall or once
left about the partitions with torment
and the rest of the remaining wild lanes
so he's either some people think that he
was going to be the now the leader of
the wild lanes but I think that
immediately would be abandoned him what
he'd he just had been given so I think
he's probably more likely to be scouting
either a new location for them like
potentially taking them back to hardhome
or something like that
and just giving a home back to the wild
lanes remember he he took these people
from the place that they call their home
and the true north they don't think of
the north as you know actually that and
close to with their home they've been
offered land there before and they said
they weren't into it
that was his vow back when he was with
Ygritte was that he would be of bring
her bring them back also this episode
had grey worm and Brienne kind of pay
homage to their dead loves a lot like
John is doing right here putting flowers
on the grave yeah yeah but also I think
that you know we talked a little bit
about what the imagery of that last shot
is and what's what you know it reminded
us of yeah absolutely I mean looking at
the the imagery of these living
breathing humans going northward and
disappearing into the mysterious forests
so many of the shots in this final scene
echoed the prologue scene of the series
of the three Night's Watch Rangers going
north of the wall and seeing these this
evidence of this creepy existential
threat from the White Walkers coming
south through the trees of dead children
resurrected with blue eyes as these kind
of zombies this is kind of a direct
thematic counterpoint to that of showing
humans going further north and there's
also I think it's important that we see
children and John is entering the forest
he is basically a resurrected figure
children of the forest maybe you could
argue in some kind of fan fiction future
that we all have of this show could John
become a new night king type figure in
the game of thrones books there's they
don't have the night king as we saw him
on the show at least yet but there is a
character named the night's king who was
a former Lords Commander of the Nights
Watch who fell in love with a some
thought was a bear or a white Walker
woman and became this kind of Mythology
as figure of the night's king it's John
gonna fulfill that kind of destiny and
become this kind of half human half
resurrected zombie figure who just lives
in the north in his days until he dies
or never does we got a lot of shows
coming that could actually happen oh my
goodness okay I hope it just gets louder
at moogle Queen asks why didn't the
other kingdoms want to be independent
sweetie
earlier and why I think that if you
watch the scene in the dragon pit Sansa
is like you know what the North is gonna
stay independent immediately cuts to
Yara and she's like what like we could
ask that
yeah that's an option but so it is a
really really great question because
that moment seemed like it should be
available to everyone there so then why
doesn't your ask for the same thing for
the Iron Islands also why doesn't thorne
ask right is it just because Yara
gradually had been promised some kind of
autonomy and independence by Daenerys
and Doran historically has always been
the part of the continent that the
targets have struggled to invade and
control I think a good answer simply is
that Sansa Stark and the northern forces
are surrounding the city right now
whereas militarily speaking there is no
remaining Navy of the Iron Islands
you're on used all of it it's been
destroyed and for as far as we know we
don't know what the Dornish forces are I
think the last time we saw any kind of
Dornish forces were was the navy that
you're on first sacked in season 7
episode 2 so it might just be a question
of military might the north still has a
standing army that poses the threat to
the unsullied and in the south whereas
these other forces despite their
promises that they've heard to them to
them for independence just don't have
the the might to back it up it could be
that I also think it could be a clue or
hint toward the dream of spring right
which spring is representative of peace
that's what you're a Greyjoy taking over
the Iron Islands is supposed to
represent right we we know that her
family you know they don't so they they
stack they pillage and she vowed to
change that that if she were selected as
the next leader that she would reign
honestly kind of like catch them up to
Westeros because they were they were
still from leftover from a different
time in this version of government that
she's now this is witness to this this
concept that maybe things can be
different
maybe we will actually be listened to
now we'll be heard she's helping
choose the king her boat technically
would not have mattered if she can vote
her differently but this is an example
that things are going to be different
and they potentially could be you know
at least more peaceful for a time and
Yara Greyjoy's iron islands don't need
to behave the way her father's did yeah
which was multiple rebellions and even
throughout the show before the show yeah
she's she's keeping up to her own bowels
yeah these kingdoms might see a benefit
and trying to work with a monarch like
bran the broken maybe they see some
weakness say that they could try to
exploit and they want to continue to try
to play this game where as santa has
made promises to her other northern
bannermen that they would be an
independent nation these other two
didn't necessarily make that promise
yeah speaking of the way that you could
work with bran the broken and not this
council but the small council I think
that there's it's very telling the way
that small council is set up we're gonna
talk about that in just a second but
real quick we just got to give a shout
out to a few more sponsors that help us
bring Westeros weekly to you and all of
our Game of Thrones content at this
season oh yes
starting with a care of it's a
subscription service that makes it
really easy to get personalized vitamins
and more delivered straight to your door
now that game of Thrones is over maybe
you have some more time to get back in
your routine help you feel your
healthiest with care of you take a fun
online quiz about your diet and
lifestyle and you get a personal science
back recommendation for vitamins protein
powders and more they take the guesswork
out of being healthy and make it really
easy and convenient here so this is like
a box I was sent from Kara with just
like these little packs of multivitamins
vitamin C whatever I told them that I
needed and they determined for me that
will help with my diet and they have
these packages are easy to grab and go
like if you don't wanna take it right
away but you know once you get to work
you'll be able to drink some water and
you can take them throughout the day
when it's convenient for you rather than
having a big pill bottle and you will
easily forget about it those who just
care in your pocket and with the care of
app you can earn rewards for taking your
vitamins which is great it gives you
kind of like it's like other than health
other than how it should be reward
enough itself but let's be honest we
don't always take care of ourselves
this kind of makes it easy to track
forward 30% off your first care of order
go to take care of comm and enter promo
code Westeros 30 again that's take care
of comm and promo code Westeros 30 for
30% off
your first order it's not great so
thanks to care of for helping us out
here and then our final sponsor this
week is a way travel they're a design
company that makes the world's coolest
suitcases they're made of a
polycarbonate material that's strong and
superlight perfect for traveling north
of the wall if wildin friends and your
direwolf want you to go with them to New
York we use these away traveling so that
too yeah so this is there everywhere bag
which is just great for small trips and
even just you know my day-to-day life
some of their other models even come
with a built in battery to charge your
electronic accessories very cool yep you
get your own cool await you can get your
own cool away luggage at away travel.com
slash rock stars and use promo code rock
stars 20 for $20 off your order
again that's away travel.com slash rock
stars and use the promo code rock stars
20 for $20 off spat it at us this time
maybe's mad at me at Ron McDowell asks
why does brand need a master of whispers
this is what we were getting at a second
ago this idea of bran having a clearly a
small council here that was in my
opinion filled in order of importance
for what he needs and also for the time
that were going into so a lot of people
are asking here why does he need a
master of whisperers cuz he knows
everything right that's one of the the
big questions but that's also I think
something that they're trying to point
out to us is he also doesn't have a
master of war yeah either well that it
but what does he have right he has the
people in place that will help rebuild
yeah reconstruction efforts rebuilding
the economy and having of course a
Kingsguard and having an arch maester to
remind us of history which is something
that's important to brand but in terms
of a master [ __ ] we should remind
ourselves a master of war did not exist
until Cersei recently reorganized a
small cast Council and then awarded that
to her uncle Kevan has a way to try to
reconsolidate power it's it's some could
argue just like the Bush administration
creating the Department of Homeland
Security it's not a historically thing
it just in that time it became something
that was needed you could also say that
like the master of whispers this is
something that like there
Chris held previously it's and that
Qyburn held recently it's it's almost
like the Westeros equivalent to the FBI
or a spy espionage Network information
brand as a three-eyed raven I think
people will sometimes overestimate his
powers we don't know if you can see
everything to specific photographic
detail it seems like he gets these kind
of metaphorical images that he has to
reassemble in his head maybe he wants a
master of whispers as a way that like
when we go through TSA studies have
shown that the TSA at the airport don't
listen terrorists doesn't always prevent
like you can actually slip through a lot
of things but is there for symbolic
reminders to remind people hey you're
being watched maybe don't try to screw
with us the 1984 thought police it's
just the concept that they will know
what you're what you're doing is the
deterrent right on its own I also think
though that it's kind of telling what
we're looking at here for where we're
probably headed toward and that's a
post-war reconstruction effort which
would tell you if you're wondering
what's Westeros like in a week what's
Westeros like in a year and what's
Westeros like in five years there
probably are going to be a lot of babies
but honestly there's gonna be a
stimulated economy I mean this is like
the nerdiest thing you can bring up but
they oh this is an infrastructure plan
that they're going into that's a lot of
jobs for a lot of people that's a lot of
money needing to move around that
actually is a stimulus that a lot of
like our country honestly is looking to
go into an infrastructure plan and
rebuild the highways and do things like
that because it's so good for the people
so they probably are actually gonna have
a time of prosperity as well as the time
of peace which tends to mean a time of a
lot of babies which is gonna replace a
lot of dead people that recently there's
a lot of real estate around right now I
guess you have to build it up yourself -
there you go even more jobs so they're
actually probably headed toward probably
one how can I say probably achill more
times
they're probably headed toward one of
the most prosperous times of westeros
history yeah and it's not necessarily
proven that he wants a master but you
just notice that there is no master of
whisperers or master of war and maybe
that's just something that bran just
happened to notice and it's he pointed
out so that we can realize oh that's
these things are not a priority right
now for the
current small council and leadership
yeah come at me okay you wanna take this
one yeah I just wanted to know why the
bird can't make it other way over here
if the bird can fly but it's got a human
baby bird suhuf it's adorable
at Ilana loves DW wants to know what are
the unsullied and Dothraki going to do
now okay yes so we know that grey worm
in the unsullied are sailing to the Isle
of Knauth that was the homeland of
Masson day
it's south of Illyria it's in the
continent of soros which is its south
there's a lot of islands rose it's
pretty it's yeah it's unexplored what's
interesting they don't really address
this in the show but in the world of
Westeros they contain these flesh-eating
butterflies right it's their only manner
of defense because the people of nought
are very trusting unfortunately and
that's why they're prone I mean they're
so weak that the butterflies were able
to get the flutterflies ranked them on
the food chain right right
so but they Davos did say that they're
known for their butterflies but they
haven't been established as flesh-eating
in a show anyway so but he's bringing
them back or he's it sounds like he's
bringing Musante back to bury her there
as they kind of promised each other and
right before the Battle of Winterfell
that we want to retire to the beach and
maybe that seems like where the
unsullied gotta go also she was implying
that she wanted her people protected
right army there of protection not a
army of people that will procreate there
and increase increase no but these these
Southern Isles are often where slaves
are gathered from so it seems like maybe
the unsub label kind of stopped the
slave trade to s yeah you know hopefully
word gets to not before they do because
otherwise it's like hi my name is grey
worm you guys don't know me but uh I
think I should run things here now with
my army who we're not here to kill you
guys I swear like it's a pretty intense
story to try to catch them up on like do
you guys remember my Sande oh you don't
okay it's gonna be very difficult to
explain yeah
the Dothraki are an interesting question
though because we did see a couple
Dothraki just kind of hanging out by the
docks when John was being brought well
you would think one of them would at
least give John a stink eye for killing
their Khaleesi but they're known as like
Kathy's Viking Genghis Khan style
warriors they rape they pillage they
they don't really settle places and they
don't like they don't make good
neighbors
they also followed by the way the the
person who killed their cow that's yeah
yeah so nothing I don't think they're
gonna follow John either I just mean
like you know they're loyal with limits
right so I would assume they're going to
move on maybe the fact that they were
shown by the duck shows that they're
going to sail somewhere else to one of
the Free Cities are back to Essos herb
yeah I mean they have biased attract
right there's a whole city where they
reign supreme remember if it's burned
enter the temples that are in Temple but
and and all the old calls are gone so
there's a there's a power void there too
that they can fill yeah they could
become a new mercenary army there's
there's lots of options yeah if you're
if you're a Dothraki you're you're okay
yeah
[Music]
okay so em are Pibbs asks how is tyrion
not mentioned in A Song of Ice and Fire
yeah so how did he not make it into the
book first of all I know that you know
it was Artemis cerebro's we had already
kind of seen him was like oh I'm dr.
Bose that I've chronically in the wars
following the death of King Robert the
first and he had that you know why don't
you give it a better name moment I still
wish that Sam was the one that wrote the
whole thing and maybe if it was
something like that of course Tyrion
would have made it in but it also I
think it's kind of calling out that
history isn't about the the people who
you know just played a role
it's what Tyrion said right it's about
the story you you follow people in these
stories and in our own history you know
we know the generals of the Civil War
and we know the president at a time we
don't know you know some of you do but
the chief of staff of the president at
the time right the great counsellors of
time
I mean Lincoln famously had his team of
rivals that were advising him but can
you name them any of them if you open a
good history textbook they tell you they
tell you who like who was on his team of
rivals and Seward and his you know other
people you know who Henry Clay is if
you're taking a push even though he
wasn't a president he was a guy who
brokered a lot of big deals the way
Tyrion has kind of been but you have
McGraw Hill and you have the p1 oral
history you have all these different
textbook companies
all you know comparing notes and putting
their versions out they got one yeah I
think this was like a moment that's kind
of in a on the surface jokingly
shortchanging tyrion is a guy who has
been told before that his whatever he
does will not make it into the history
books just because he in his words is an
imp and people never honor them properly
but I like to see it as his story is
still yet to be written the same way
that Brienne had to kind of fill in
Jamie's obituary and kind of tell his
story
tn Tyrians task is still ahead of him
like he has to fix all of his mistakes
he spend the rest of his life rebuilding
this country so he his stories still yet
to be written and hopefully Sam can add
a chapter once tyrion fixes everything
in Westeros yeah here's here's a for
those of you Tyrion fans right now isn't
the time but he totally could be the
next king sure you know could be chosen
bran we don't know what's gonna happen
with bran i won honest he's either gonna
live a thousand years he's gonna turn
into a tree he's gonna go move into a
cave or you know he's just kind of a
mortal man and he could die
Hey I mean people with his kind of
injury honestly they do tend to die
younger you know but so so do people
with what Tarina has so but if he does
live long enough I think he could be
exactly the person who I was just
talking about the prosperity they're
about to have it could be him as the
architect of it who essentially can run
on a campaign of that in the future yeah
for sure
[Music]
louder than it is efficient in any other
way as it is the reading order wants to
know why does the Nights Watch still
exist yeah that's a good question we saw
at the end of the episode not much of it
exists like there are the people in
Castle black but it seems most of them
are wildlings and tormund Westeros we
should acknowledge still needs
protection from whatever might be north
of the wall it seems like the night king
the White Walkers that threat is
vanquished but they could rise up again
there could be other unforeseen threats
really the wall represents a fear of the
unknown whatever is beyond that night of
darkness did you just say it really
briefly the wildlings like torment is a
character who's gone through it was just
the White Walkers in fact most of the
nights Watchmen at the begin of this
series were
just going out and fighting well yeah
but then also I like to think of the
Nights Watch as the the solution that is
instead of execution and a true jail or
prison it's kind of a men's work colony
right a colony where you can find
Redemption right and so that gives you
the solution of people who break these
you know antiquated laws a lot of a lot
of scenarios where they don't deserve
death they also don't deserve you know
slavery or extreme imprisonment but they
need to be punished in some way and I
think it's actually one of the most
advanced things they have is this
alternate punishment right away rather
than execution a way forward to come
back from the brink yeah yeah we got
another one bird it's learning to speak
more at Chad's trucker 40 asks why would
drogon melt the throne weight doesn't
have to do with war the Burgess
unprovoked said wars is that a threat
for what is a great addiction bird so
dragons do have a special connection to
their riders and all the Dragons have
had a special connection to their mother
Daenerys the three that we've seen in
the show she didn't have to scream
Turkish every time she wanted rogue on
to torch something in King's Landing or
like what like in other battles the
Dragons just kind of knew you know kind
of yeah yes but she tugged in her ear I
think so
likewise I think he knew that her drive
who sit on that throne is what ended up
killing her that like he kind of
recognized it as the true evil that was
corrupting all these characters like the
Ring of Power that needed to be
destroyed they do have these this kind
of magical cosmic understanding of how
things work so that could have been the
reason why I do like that some people
said that he thought that Dany just
tripped and fell on one of the swords
yeah she's a pointy thing through her
sees a bunch of pointy things over there
yeah so I think that kind of that cosmic
understanding is the best interpretation
we have of that yeah advanced figure hi
Sylvia it's Sylvia asked where did
drogon take Danny at the end of this
right so the closest we get to hearing
where drogon is
and ideally he hasn't dropped her off in
the ocean on his way is we heard that he
was spotted flying east I mean anything
I think we can it's it's hard to find
those thoughts reliable but I think it
Dragan is something that people will
spot as it goes around so it probably is
on its way to or even beyond esos it
could be going back toward the the great
grass sea of the Dothraki where he was
born
sure in that area and also you know it's
very significant to his mother
there's also old Valyria where dragons
originally came from it's also where
Targaryen came yeah and there's a theory
that drogon might actually be a female
or might have laid some eggs or
something an old Valyria and that's why
I Tyrion my interest spotted drogon when
they were going through the doom of
Valyria or maybe you could be going back
to the Shadowlands east of us I you know
and there's the some people say that's
where the the eggs came from originally
so he could be going back to the source
of the eggs right where the dragons
might still be a lot of people there's
two theories out there I wanna
acknowledge really quick one is that
drogon is taking dinero somewhere to be
resurrected by a red priestess or
something we don't think that's
happening yeah I think it would kind of
[ __ ] on the whole thing but there's
another theory that dragons by
reentering
history in this place this is also the
rebirth of magic these people obviously
magic has played quite a role on the
show so I think I just wanna acknowledge
right there that yeah I'm really into
the idea that drogon somehow begets more
dragons whether or not it's frog DNA or
what it is it does it that's what I'm
hoping for for sure so we got another
question but this one's actually you
stay right there bird you don't move
because this one is also from our New
York a show where we had our other
Stardust winner ask a question live on
stage with us so let's kick to that
question from Carly Anne hi guys um so
I'm wondering I think and this is
probably big question where is aria
going she's going west of Westeros is
that a new series what could we find
there it's past the edge of the math
love to hear what your guys's are
thinking cuz I want to know where sari
is going that's the next show I'm
watching I give it a great question and
love the costume a very
yes sir see later see yeah absolutely
you think all right yes I wonderful
question and I I love the mystery and
the promise that it opens up west of
Westeros is completely off the map
completely unknown we don't know what
kind of globe were working with here in
Westeros
so yeah you better hope it's not
actually flat right I like the idea that
things are expanding in all different
corners of the globe right John is going
north grey worm is going south to the
isle of North watch out for those
butterflies by the way they're supposed
to be poisonous enough Rogan and
Denise's corpse are going east somewhere
and sort of wondered are they going to
the old Valyria yeah but they are going
east and then Arya's going west things
are expanding beyond the content of
Westeros which is no longer a focus of
concern
it's what's next and what is beyond the
edge of that map so with Aria I like to
think there's another continent over
there maybe she'll just go all the way
around and then we'll be back in the
shadow lands that are east and so fine
as we did when we explored west connects
this is actually round yeah I think it
makes a lot of sense there's a lot of
parallels obviously with the the world
of Westeros and earth and I mean
honestly she's set up to potentially
encounter a bunch of natives and then
give them malaria thank you so much to
start us for flying those two out I've
never been so limit just to be clear got
that joke in at the end which was so
yeah but moving on to our kill count so
again not a ton of bloodshed in this
episode except John of course killing
Daenerys always be my queen and then a
grey worm who we saw kill one Lannister
soldier probably killed everyone in that
lab he's moving on to the next one so he
wins that kill count I guess we're
looking for winners in that moment but
it wasn't active for it or what is it
active or and I work right a war crime
yeah moving on to the death pool so at
the beginning of the season we invited
all of you to participate in a death
pool at guess the throne calm over 2,000
people participated and we had one
winner and that crazy one person got
essentially everything all right
and nailed the three bonus questions of
who would die first
this was this person's name it's Tammy
Tammy thank you just waiting and well
done
okay so Tammy got the three bonus
questions right of who would die first
which is beric Dondarrion of the
different options who were given who
would die last Daenerys on the show and
who would sit on the Iron Throne she
correctly guessed that it was brand so
Tammy we aren't able to find your
information because we weren't able to
get on-site tweeted us let us know I'd
let us know but I'd then send us a DM
it's you haven't sort of conversation
with what we got for you
I also a off-screen producer can you
tell us what places we came in about
what would I come in eighth place oh wow
eighth place of two thousand oh three
hundred and ninety eighth I came in
three Wow
I Oh bummer I was ahead of you for yeah
I don't know how I missed on Meera Reed
she was just how is that yeah I was
rigged
I thought Arya was gonna die I thought
Varys would live I thought grey worm and
Jorah were gonna die tormund how did he
survive that's so crazy I do think I was
right about the last person who died I
said Daenerys no yeah and I missed all
the bonus questions I I said that Euron
would be the first to die I said that
the night king would sit on the Iron
Throne yeah that was pretty bad and you
said the whole thing was a dream right
it was all the dream and off-screen
producer came in tied for 86 oh yeah you
can't you can't work for a living yeah
and now it's time for our Power Rankings
it's part of the show where you guys
decide who you thought won the episode
this is an interesting one we sent out
our Twitter poll last night and last
night you voted is fairly even but in
third place 24.8% said brand brand a
broken the new king of the six kingdoms
of the six realms but not seven so maybe
that's why he didn't come in first place
right right
and maybe it didn't feel like so much of
a victory since someone else gave him
that victory which is our second place
winner with 27 point two percent of the
vote tyrion lanister seemed to be like a
more power player that episode
more of you felt that he was the power
winner well I mean dude he comes out of
a prison cell I gets told by a grey worm
you're a prisoner you're not here to
talk and then delivers a monologue for
four minutes where he decides the king
of westeros yeah he had enough speech
but first place most of you felt with
29.5 percent of the vote Sansa Stark
Queen the queen of do Norv sit down
uncle yeah definitely a powerful victory
for her so whatever you felt that maybe
she deserved to have the Iron Throne or
to be ruler of Westeros this in more
ways than some are is a big victory for
her and we should all feel great for it
surprised John didn't up in the top
three personally speaking maybe people
felt that his yeah but that's a powerful
thing he was able to fulfill destiny and
kill the mother of dragons and got away
with it
I think it's about the well technically
I mean according to them North with his
dog how is that a prison sentence yeah I
mean maybe you would've been fourth I
want to give a shout out real quick to
bran because I was really funny picture
we had of him but he had that those
cherry red lips that I have and I so
often feel very alone about and I I've
seen my kool-aid drinking brother I
never noticed yep
well that's been enough for this
Westeros weekly not for the whole season
we're gonna make at least another one of
these and then as many as you'll have
but thank you so much for watching or
listening to these do not forget to
subscribe to the Westeros weekly podcast
feed that I know for a fact it's going
to continue on whether or not we make
exactly the same things on the You Tube
channel
we got really interesting very fun stuff
actually coming out for the essentially
Game of Thrones related stuff at the
podcast feed but then also our new MCU
podcast feed inside Marvel's doing great
make sure to follow that one as well
it's got all of our content about Marvel
in general but still remnants of our
Avengers endgame stuff and what it all
means yeah a lot of you are worried like
oh we will have nothing to watch from
you guys anymore guys we're just getting
started it's like we're the HBO promos
of like it begins now like really we are
rounding a corner and launching so many
new things on this channel because of
what we've been able to do with Game of
Thrones so we're grateful that it exists
it were great for all of you guys and we
look forward to what comes next as you
should as well so make sure to follow
or our channel and our company on
twitter at new rock stars and all over
the place on instagram we do all sorts
of fun stuff everywhere and tweet us
anything related to Game of Thrones your
questions on going well we're gonna use
them for video ideas you can use the
hashtag Westeros weekly to make sure we
find those you can follow me on twitter
at fimo and on instagram at philip
molina you can follow me at ei Vox all
right we've got a lot of great videos
and podcasts coming up so stay tuned
guys thank you so much for the season we
got so much more coming so about it
[Music]